in this video we'll talk about cancer
metastasis
so what is cancer metastasis the
development of a secondary tumor in a
part of the body that is distant from
the original primary tumor is known as
metastasis so imagine you have a tumor
in this particular portion of the body
from this portion another tumor forms at
a distinct location in the body and this
phenomenon is known as cancer metastasis
it is metastasis which is making cancer
so difficult to treat imagine you treat
your cancer which happened in the hand
but before even treatment it can spread
into different portions of your body so
even if treatment works for one region
there would be secondary spread in other
regions so cancer cells can dislodge
from one particular location and travel
through the blood vessels or lymphatics
and reach another location to colonize
that place
so there are different classifications
of cancer metastasis there is primary
metastasis
and there is secondary metastasis
secondary metastasis means after primary
metastasis cancer cells move into
another location again
which makes the thing even more
complicated
so let's talk about the stages of cancer
metastasis
so cancer metastasis begins with the
cellular process of epithelial to
mesenchymal transition
epithelial cells are fixed on a basal
membrane and it doesn't move all around
the body in contrast the mesenchymal
cells can dislodge from the basal lamina
and can move throughout the different
regions of the body
so the epithelial to mesenchymal
transition is the first step of
metastasis
then there would be Invasion where the
mesenchymal cells would invade through
the extracellular Matrix and it would
undergo a process known as
introversation so it would get through
the blood vessels and enter the blood
vessels either blood vessel or also
lymphatics as well
then it circulates through the
lymphatics and it extravasation occurs
just like a neutrophil or any immune
cell and it populates a new location and
it forms a colony
so the probability of colonization and
successful extravasation is very low but
even after that metastasis happens
so people are not really clear about the
entire mechanism but let us talk about
the mechanism in bit more details so but
before I should tell you that most of
the carcinomas spread via lymphatics
whereas most of the sarcomas spread
hematogeneously through the blood
vessels
if we talk about organs that are
affected by this metastatic processes
the first thing that gets affected is
the lymph node
and next liver and lung are the most
common sites for metastasis
in fact fifty percent of the brain
tumors are actually result of metastasis
okay let's talk about molecular
mechanisms of metastasis in order to
understand molecular mechanism we have
to first understand what is epithelial
to mesenchymal transition
so this is an epithelial cell and these
in yellow the epithelial cell has
specific characteristics they have cell
to cell adherence and tight junctions
they have hemidase mode desmosomes which
connect them to the basement
they have Epico basal polarity that
means their apical side and the basal
side are quite different from each other
based on molecular marker expression
now all these features are disrupted in
a
cell so epithelial characters are now
abolished and new characters are
acquired a cell which is undergoing EMT
so one of the Hallmark features of EMT
is loss of cell adhesion loss of Epico
basal polarity cleavage and invasion of
the basal lamina and ultimately
gaining of a migratory capacity one can
understand these better with molecular
signatures for example there are
distinct epithelial molecular signature
such as epithelial catering cytokeratin
zo1 which is a adhere which is a tight
Junction marker laminin
Etc whereas the mesenchymal cell
upregulates vimentine l-caterine
fibronectin and proteins like snail
sludge Alpha SMA Etc
so epithelial and mesenchymal transition
is not an
uncommon process when it comes to human
body because during the nervous system
development the neural crest cells
undergoes the EMT and this is completely
normal
during the formation of mesoderm there
is also epithelial to mesenchymal
transition
in fact wound healing process requires
this kind of transition as well
so this is not a harmful process as such
but when it happens in context of cancer
this could be quite detrimental so let's
talk about the factors that are involved
in EMT it turns out there are molecular
factors and transcription factors like
zeb1 twist and snail which are highly
involved in the process of epithelial to
mesenchymal transition experiments has
shown that if you ectopically express
these transcription factors to any
epithelia they undergo this
transformation into mesenchyme in cancer
cells it has been shown that many cases
these transcription factors are
upregulated or mutations of these
transcription factors are often
associated with cancer
so all of these factors modulate
adherence Junctions and tight junctions
Integrity it also modulates actin
Regulators we can which can allow the
change in cell shape
also it triggers cytoskeletal
rearrangement
another important thing that we are
going to discuss in details is the
Matrix metaloproteinases
these Matrix metaloproteinases can act
on The extracellular Matrix and dissolve
The extracellular Matrix which would
make the Detachment more easy
there are several signaling Pathways
which converge into
these particular transcription Factor
generation
so there are signaling Pathways like
wind beta-catinine signaling pathway
there are signaling Pathways like
receptor tyrosine kinase Jack Stack TGF
beta or even not signaling pathway all
of these are implicated in terms of
cancer metastasis and one of the common
theme of all these pathway is that they
upregulate Z1 twist and snail so all
these things lead to the epithelial to
mesenchymal transition
now the Matrix
metalloproteinases or mmps are key
factor that helps in metastasis once
secreted by the cell they can break the
extracellular Matrix which would make it
easier for a mesenchymal cell to invade
now let's talk about and summarize the
determinants of metastasis so most
important determinant is the external
signal that could be growth factor
chemokines cytokine
Etc
so the cell adhesion cell cell adhesion
and cell basement addition are very
important
for metastasis additions are generally
dissolved during the metastatic
procedure second Matrix
metalloproteinases are the key factor
which can dissolve or modify the
extracellular Matrix
then there are additional factors such
as genetic mutations which make it more
susceptible or make it more likely that
a cell would metastasize
and ultimately these days it has been
shown that epigenetic modifications
could be also a leading cause for cancer
metastasis so I hope in this video you
got some idea about cancer metastasis
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my Facebook and Instagram page
you can support our Channel using super
tanks
see you in next video
Jesus